échelle Drucker nous menace je ne
prendrai jamais ma retraite
Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
ça va Stéphane
alors une semaine très noire Thierry
pour le gouvernement
défaites en rugby grève générale et
séparation des Sarkozy coup de chapeau
au Figaro Magazine qui quelques heures
avant France-Angleterre titré le
parcours sportif du 15 de France dans
cette Coupe du monde n'est pas sans
évoquer l'itinéraire politique de
Nicolas Sarkozy
une fois qu'on est d'accord avec le
Figaro
on a perdu cette fois aucune image du
président dans les vestiaires une seule
photo parue où l'on sent déjà que la
défaite ça fait mal au cul
la semaine prochaine la porte devient
secrétaire d'État enfin un métier
d'homme adieu l'état fiole
il sera commandé par un vrai demi
d'ouverture Roselyne Bachelot qui cette
semaine lui a déjà claqué son beignet
on a on a perdu du coup le gouvernement
doute hier François Fillon indiquait le
nouveau chiffre de la croissance
dans VSD Brice hortefe fait flouter ses
enfants blond et habillé en bon point
Édouard Amaury et Maxence n'ont pas à
redouter de tests ADN
[Applaudissements]
pour finir Michel Drucker nous menace je
ne prendrai jamais ma retraite
et on termine avec le vrai coup dur de
la semaine la séparation des Sarkozy
pour l'occasion Frédéric Mitterrand a
souhaité rendre hommage à ce couple
mythique
bonsoir Après le cocorico est masculin
de notre corps que Gaulois le chant du
signe du couple Sarkozy s'achève
sortie sans gloire pour ceux qu'on
surnommate trop vite les Kennedy à la
française
finir au tribunal de Nanterre moins
glamour me direz-vous que le cuir d'une
Lincoln décapotable à Dallas
Nanterre dernier acte d'un improbable
histoire d'amour des marais il y a 20
ans entre un homme politique les
députélec de Jacques Martin au pourquoi
préféré l'austérité froide d'un
ministère aux soirées entre potes où
l'on chante à la pêche au moules moules
moules
20 ans d'amour ou Cécilia EDA Nicolas
affranchir tous les obstacles comme
Calais un cube sous ses pieds quand il
est assis
20 ans de passion de disputes et de
rabibocharge sur l'oreiller souvenir de
cette nuit torride ovationnée par le
personnel du Fouquet's pourquoi dès lors
après tant d'épreuve tirait sa révérence
est-ce le fruit d'un caractère
exceptionnel ou la peur toute simple
pour une femme de père moldave et de
mère espagnole de subir un test ADN
goodbye Cécilia dommage vous étiez plus
bandante que Bernadette et surtout bravo
pour le coup de l'angine blanche faire
semblant d'être malade pour ne pas
serrer la main d'un homme qui revendique
la torture en Irak chapeau sans vous
Nicolas n'a plus son cube son équilibre
peut-être le début de la fin qui sait
bonsoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu